[Music]
I always say when ICUs Vavoom that is
one way to describe Sofia vegara but the
thing I love about her she always has
embraced is why shouldn't a okay then
she's totally comfortable with their
signature curves of course so when she
was approached to do this new naked
cover shoot she said of course being
naked I think it's powerful sensual and
it can be fun wearing her confidence a
smile but nothing else Sofia Vergara is
owning the cover of women's health naked
issue
I'm Latin so we grew up going to the
beach in a g-string hi I'm 44 no matter
how much you take care of yourself is
that reality we all age and you have to
raise it embracing every inch of her
enviable curves which were framed
provides very strategic hair placements
inside the pages Sofia reveals her
secrets to being fit and fearless after
turning 45 died why she keeps it clean
until she starts cheating on Thursdays
she also exercises three to four days a
week with a trainer but like so many
struggles to get it done saying quote
I'm in a bad mood two hours before I'm
in a bad mood while I'm doing it I'm in
a bad mood at the end because I have to
schedule the next class husband of
nearly two years Joe Manganiello helps
her stay accountable people to my home
Jenn so there's no excuses I am a
morning person so if I don't do it in
the morning then working out for me
becomes like I find any excuse not to do
it and as her unstoppable work ethic
which has helped Sophia redefined what a
Hollywood leading lady can look like
it's not just the the Barbie doll in the
cover
it's like real woman before it was a
little bit more straight to how women
were supposed to to look things have
changed
you
[Music]